what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here so I'm gonna watch the next three
episodes that the defenders can only
post about like five to ten minutes
worth of video of the reaction part by
the time I actually wrap up the series
Andrew Gordon from the movie source
Channel and I will be doing a full
series review but in the meantime let's
watch the next four episodes
here we go just had their hallway five
just had the hallway fight yo now
hopefully they talk this time I wanted
like dialogue scenes this restaurant
[Music]
damn straight love either all
discovering their powers they still got
sexual tension yeah just getting back
into nothing could top their sex love
that he's still wearing the Scoob is
gonna yeah we met
[Music]
what is that hard to do
we're not any random orbit up
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
so with it fight is really over there
why don't use my car for a second there
you know trust
mmm-hmm private investigator did you
smashed it god I love their interaction
I'm just stating the obvious
I love it they sleeve funny how you're
hiding your face themselves you want
nothing and I want zero to do with this
ancient organization I just went track
my case Jeff you rather me sprung into
action I think you want the same thing
[Music]
come on man join the tomb you know it's
going that way anyway so might as well
do the dirty yeah boy
[Music]
there is now
[Music]
okay I'm loving it I'm loving it
[Music]
Oh badass bye
[Music]
[Music]
Jessica
Oh defenders assemble
[Music]
Shiina kicked her while she was down man
[Music]
all right oh yeah this is like the
assembly episode are I cool
ah thank you for the binge-watching
format [ __ ] before I hop onto the next
episode I'll give you guys my quick
thoughts on this Ruby I've heard that
opening scene could have been like a
teaser prom I'm glad they didn't put it
online at the same time if they did like
you know a little bit of extra marketing
which I don't need didn't need to do but
if they did I felt like that opening
scene here well my name is Matthew could
have been like a good clip to release I
really enjoy the hell out of this
episode for me personally it's giving me
everything that I was hoping to gain
from watching this show like these four
people who don't work well with others
and having to learn to work together and
put their egos to the side I love that
stick showed up at the restaurant became
the guy with all the exposition all the
details on how what everything's going
down we started getting details on who
stick is and why he's doing what he does
I'm kind of hoping the show doesn't do
this but it seems like it's setting up
for this to happen I'm getting the
impression that they're probably gonna
kill off stick in this it's a crossover
series and usually when you do like a
crossover like this I've been predicting
to be Claire or stick who would die in
this series and I'm getting a strong
impression it's gonna be stick who dies
this time around like I don't want her
to happen I love the dynamics he has
with Charlie Cox but now that he's
revealed who he is that he's part of the
chase he follows the leaders of Conlon
and the iron fist it just seems like
he's gonna die and honestly if he does
die comments are currently disabled so
no one's been able to ruin that for me
if he does die that's seen when Danny
went and Luke were talking to the table
I thought it was great
Danny ran is warming up a [ __ ] ton more
to me than he did when I was watching
iron fist season one like for my
understanding the overall reception of
Danny ran still is not highly regarded
but personally I'm really enjoying the
chemistry he's forming with Luke Cage
the fact that Danny's just like spoiled
cocky dude and it seems like unaware of
these attitude traits
I love how Luke just constantly calls
him out on his [ __ ] and rolls his
eyes a lot and because Luke is doing
that and we can see who Danny is and the
way the show is kind of capturing who
Danny is through Luke's perspective it
makes Danny just a little bit more
likable to me and I do enjoy how the
show was building up the mantle of iron
fist just how important Danny
and truly is more like more than just a
skill and a unit for the team but an
overall integral piece for both the good
guys and the bad guys the hand I'm not
entirely sure yet why Matt and stick are
not revealing that they know Elektra I
know they don't really know these guys
so that does sort of make sense to me
and knowing that I'm sure he's gonna try
to pull some [ __ ] what he's gonna try to
get a lecture it's me it's Matt you know
you're a lecturer try to get her to come
out of this whole black sky thing and I
love a lecture of what season two of
daredevil I adored her but I'm also
hoping the show doesn't go down some
conventional route where she turns into
some good guy at the end but you know I
wait and find out and I'm really
enjoying Sigourney Weaver's performance
of Alexandra like the writing of her
character I think is good but I think
Sigourney Weaver brings a lot to the
table here that scene where she just
shows up at the restaurant love that
moment I feel like a lot of times in
movies and shows like this there's
usually someone who speaks for the big
baddie of the show you know like Luke
Cage had shades season one a daredevil
had a guy I can't remember his name
Wally Willy do with the glasses - Karen
shot so I just love that Sigourney
Weaver shows up and does all the talking
herself just handles business herself
and for you know a little while I've
been thinking like this doesn't feel so
personal as an involvement for Jessica
Jones to be in this mission I guess are
kind of going does she really need to be
here but I can see that this show is
taking time to have it be a personal
involvement for her relationship that
she's developing with the victim's wife
and the victims daughter of the case
that she's taken on and I find it to be
powerful enough motivation for her to be
involved knowing Jessica Jones is
characters so yeah overall you know I
thought was a really great episode
there's not much action in it the last
episode gave me the fiber they all come
together this episode gave me the
moments where they're all talking with
each other this shows giving me what I
want it's a crossover show it's giving
me the fanservice that I've been wanting
and I really have been enjoying it all
right well I'm on to the next episode
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
become a patron eject over at our
patreon today you follow me at the Greg
alley yada yada yada